okay so we talked about cron art art and
res karat and Lil Lilia that's just
right name you have $100,000 to put in
one which one you're gonna do mmm all
right let's take a look
it's not gonna be cron for me I'm also
gonna say it's not gonna be Lilia
because even though I like the market
for all those reasons we mentioned I
don't know why this is the winning
company I don't see them doing anything
special and this is the what we have to
tell people is once you meet the person
behind it that could totally change your
decision crucial is right this is not
based on the people at all because you
could beat someone and you're like
they're so formidable that's like you
don't care what you sell them in right I
think if I was gonna do this this is
crazy to me that I'm even saying this
but I think I would be putting it in
Arden rez I think I would put it in
because I think if they can get the
marketplace spun up it's gonna be
valuable and I think that this is an
overlooked marketplace so overlooked
market so I like that it's a marketplace
as a model not lead-gen not not anything
else and then they on the other side I
think if they can get I have a feeling
that the sort of fine art marketplace
has not been affected by technology in
the same way as all the other industries
have and so I'm curious to see what they
can do so I would bet the hunter K on
the art and res and I would write it off
as a loss because I would assume it's
going to be a loss all right I would do
a cron okay why cron I just think it's
it's super easy for them to be in
default survival it's so easy like I
think that they can get to like $100,000
in monthly revenue like really fast I
think their churn might be high but III
think that it's just because of the
market size and because it's an impulse
buy and if this just saves you a little
bit of time I just think that they can
get to 10 or 30 million dollars in
recurring revenue inside three or four
years with very little capital and so
their default alive pretty easily
and depending on how creative that
entrepreneurs are they could expand
beyond that so I'm gonna go to cron okay
I like that I don't know who would buy
them though well like for example
Microsoft BOTS sunrise calendar I
believe it was an Islander that people
really liked was a pro professional
calendar and they got bought for how
much but I know like inbox Cal bought
for 100 million for making a slicker
inbox you know by Google and then sort
of thrown away
sunrise got bought so so I think that
there's potential for an acquisition
there by one of the you know big
companies that cares about you know
enterprise and productivity and whatnot
so there's there's a chance there I just
want to be evil and just cloned half of
these things on this list
yeah that's not evil that's that's it's
not evil much as capitalism but I do it
like I some of these ideas I think are
really stellar I don't know how it's I
tell you the one that I would invest in
it's not even one we discussed and then
we got to go I'll do it in 30 seconds
company called duffel they're doing fast
deliveries on college campuses and it's
a horrible idea but go ahead not
horrible not however I'll tell you why
what they do is they buy the popular
stuff that kids want like Ben & Jerry's
and chips and whatnot beer they put it
in an apartment and then they deliver it
to you on scooter when you order it so
average cart is $16 they make $5 per
delivery and they're delivering in a
very lightweight way on the same in a
very tight to your graphic boundary so
they don't have a bunch of logistical
issues there's a company called puff or
go puff have you heard of those guys
no what's that it's this but it's it's
basically it's a vase and they're doing
over a hundred million dollars a year
right now and they're just two kids out
of I don't know Penn State or something
like that I don't know where they are
but somewhere in middle America and so
I've seen this model work I think that
this is a clock business idea you have
puffer it's good I think the websites go
puff calm Thursday and they do a hundred
million in sales you have more than that
I believe and so they're in you can see
all the different campuses there so then
how profitable are they I mean I don't
know all that right I don't have all
their financials but I mean 100 million
like their net profit they pay the dry I
mean or is it like where
the driver gets most of money and most
so they're there at 163 million a year
is the thing and I don't think they even
raise that much money like let me look
at their fundraising for forego puffs I
don't think they raise too much oh no
they've now raised a lot
how much eight hundred and sixty six
million dollars Oh described as two kids
well it was Softbank invested in them
and recently and is a huge round that's
a soft Bank backed up the truck in them
but anyways I think this market works
and actually think it's great that soft
Bank backed up the truck and put the
touch of death on this company if I'm
duffel I believe in what I'm doing
there's a lot of college campuses out
there to make this work
[Music]